she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents Rihanna and ASAP Rocky started
out as collaborators and Pals and now
the singer is opening up about taking
things out of the friend zone and
deciding to have a baby what are you
enjoying about this journey with her
right now everything about it I'm loving
it the 34 year old Mama to be stuns on
the cover of Vogue rocking a sexy orange
lace bodysuit I'm enjoying it and inside
the mag she opens up about the early
days of her relationship with Rocky who
was her friend first
[Music]
the venti Beauty founder explains that
people don't get out of the friend zone
easily with her quote I certainly took a
while to get over how much I know him
and how much he knows me because we also
know how much trouble we can land each
other in of course the lovebirds first
revealed they're expecting their first
child together back in January and a few
days later she shared this snap of her
growing baby bump on Instagram I think
I'm going to be learning more from my
kids than I could ever teach them at the
time A source told ET that the couple
enjoyed keeping the pregnancy a secret
for as long as they could but they're
thrilled to share the news with their
fans I'm just excited for what I don't
know yet you know everything is new to
me so I'm excited and it seems like Riri
and Rocky are very much on the same page
what are you enjoying most about this
journey uh Donuts so far
well besides the obvious you know I'm
looking forward to it you know this is
it's all an exciting Journey so far I'm
just taking it as it comes every week
it's something new and I'm just taking
it I'm enjoying it now Rihanna says the
pregnancy wasn't exactly planned but
wasn't not planned either quote we just
had fun and then it was just there on
the test I didn't waste any time I
called him inside and showed him and our
journey began it's a dream that's never
going to end you know like it just
because you use even after birth and
ever since announcing their news Rihanna
has put her baby bump on full display
raising the bar and absolutely crushing
maternity Style with looks like this
this that and this
I know thank you so much she tells the
mag that she's hoping to help redefine
what's considered decent for pregnant
women quote my body is doing incredible
things right now and I'm not going to be
ashamed of that this time should feel
celebratory because why should you be
hiding your pregnancy and all that
Echoes what she told ET back in February
fashion is one of my favorite things so
you know redefying what it means to even
be pregnant and maternal you know it
always it it can get uncomfortable at
times so you know you can dress the part
and pretend
foreign
[Music]